it's a it's not easy being me you know
you know a lot of people think because
they have a lot of money that you know I
live a lavish lifestyle but that's just
a misconception you know and that's what
this new movie is all about is
misconceptions more importantly the
misconception of capitalism capitalism a
love story is important because it
exposes the truth about capitalism and
the great thing is you know people can
learn all about the evils of capitalism
for only $9 at their local Cineplex when
it comes out this Friday your
controversial figure what do you say to
your critics who say that your movies
are misleading well you know facts are
subjective you know some people say that
that capitalism works some people say
that socialism works you know some
people say that the American Revolution
was a good thing and and some would say
it's bad you know and so some people
would tell you I'm fat one you know the
truth is I'm just I'm just big-boned you
know but I still mean you know obesity
is is a big problem in this country I
guess I guess I should walk more what
about things like your movie Roger and
me what about it well you did get an
interview with Roger Smith the chairman
of General Motors but the whole movie
was based on the false premise that you
didn't what do you have to say about
that pass you can't just pass what can't
we just can't we hit it there this is an
unedited interview well then I guess I
would just you know point people towards
the fact which facts exactly yeah you
know I do I guess I guess some people
would see me as a bit of a role model
you know like a Kanye West or you know a
Miley Cyrus but those are celebrities
yeah I know it's a it's a gas guzzler
but you know I'm a big guy and you can't
you can't put a price on safety you know
I helped out at the UH at the church
youth group I've said this in interviews
but a lot of people don't believe that
I'm out you know practicing Catholic I
mean you know Jesus was all about the
Socialists you know helping out your
fellow man you know it doesn't seem like
Jesus was too happy the tax collectors
yeah but see the thing is you can't take
everything in here and face at face
value you've read The DaVinci Code
she's probably dead it's probably more
uh probably a lot more authoritative you
know in my free time - III do I give
motivational speeches for the kids you
know for a small small fee and now here
to tell you why you cannot make it in
America please give it over Michael
Moore
capitalism is going to make every one of
you have terrible lice
you know that that happens sometimes you
know the truth get some people really
met but there's still good kids though
you know there's still good kids just
one big Mack please
you know they don't uh capitalism is
still gonna fall it's still you I'm
pretty sure about that I think we don't
have a Big Mac so that what do you mean
you'll have Big Macs sir we don't have
Big Macs it's Burger King but this is a
bad day you can't just edit that